en el último vídeo encontramos la
ecuación de la red de regresión la
ecuación de la recta regresión para
estos cuatro puntos lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es calcular el valor de re
cuadrada para estos cuatro puntos
calcular que también se ajuste esa recta
a los datos o mejor aún calcular qué
porcentaje que es prácticamente lo mismo
de la variación de estos puntos
especialmente la variación en que es
debida a o puede explicarse por la
variación en x y para hacer eso voy a
sacar la hoja de cálculo lo trate de
hacer con la calculadora y es más
difícil espero que no te confunda el uso
de la hoja de cálculo voy a agarrar
varias columnas aquí las hojas de
cálculo tienen funciones para hacer todo
automáticamente pero lo voy a hacer a
mano para que veas cómo se hacen los
cálculos voy a usted varias columnas
aquí esta va a ser mi columna x estás en
mi columna y esta va a ser una columna
que voy amar y asterisco esta va a ser
el valor de ye predicho por la recta
basado en el valor
esta va a ser error con la recta error
con la recta
de hecho mejor déjame llamarle cuadrado
el error con la recta cuadrado lo va a
poner como cuadrado del error
con la recta de hamels al menos espacio
entonces va a ser cuadrado del error con
la recta y la siguiente va a ser el
cuadrado del cuadrado del error no de
hecho ya tengo el cuadro del error en la
siguiente en la siguiente voy a tener el
cuadrado de la variación en g
el cuadrado de la variación de la
variación de y con respecto a su media
cuadrado con respecto a
mediavilla y creo que con estas columnas
nos basta para hacer todo
pongamos entonces el valor de nuestros
datos tenemos menos 2 como a menos 3
1 - 1 1 2 y 4 3
ahora cuál es el valor predicho por la
recta el valor predicho por la recta es
si tú le das un valor de x vas a obtener
un valor de y entonces cuando x vale
menos 2 el valor predicho para y va a
ser
la pendiente 41 sobre 42 x
el valor de x y selecciona el valor de
la celda es como un pequeño tutorial en
hojas de cálculo estoy seleccionando la
celda de 2 puede mover el cursor sobre
la celda y seleccionar así el valor de x
y esto menos
5 sobre 21 5 sobre 21 así de simple dos
puntos 1905
para que nos quede claro este valor del
estimado es el valor que va a estar
sobre la recta aquí cuando yo le doy x
igual a menos 2 el valor del estimado es
igual a menos 2 punto
1905 y cuál va a ser el error bueno pues
el error va a ser la diferencia entre el
valor de menos 3 que es el valor real
menos el valor de menos 2 punto
1905 vamos a ponerlo aquí esto va a ser
igual a entonces el error va a ser igual
al valor de i
-3 que tenemos en esta celda de 2 -
la estimación de y que tenemos en la
celda f 2 es el error pero queremos
elevarlo al cuadrado lo elevamos al
cuadrado y ya tenemos el cuadrado del
error
está bien sí está bien y ahora lo que
queremos es el cuadrado de el error del
valor de y con respecto a la media de iu
y cuál es la media de la media y aquí la
tenemos es igual a un cuarto que es
punto 25 y esto también lo queremos
elevar al cuadrado y ahora algo que es
muy divertido las hojas de cálculo es
aplicar estas fórmulas a las tres filas
restantes y nota que lo que pasó aquí
tenemos el valor predicho para el valor
correspondiente de x que es x igual a
menos 1 aquí está calculando el cuadro
de la distancia con respecto a la recta
usando el valor pueda predecir para allí
y usando el valor correspondiente de iu
y aquí hace lo mismo también calcula el
valor del cuadro de la distancia de y
con respecto a su media entonces cuál es
el total del cuadrado del error con
respecto a la recta déjame sumar esto y
me va a dar 2 puntos 73 y el total del
cuadrado del error
respecto a la media de la distancia de
ye con respecto a su media al cuadrado
esto va a ser igual a 22.75 déjame poner
en claro deja de poner muy en claro lo
que son estos números que acabamos de
calcular
voy a escribirlo por acá junto a la
gráfica el cuadro del error con respecto
a la recta el cuadro del error con
respecto a la recta lo acabamos de
calcular como 2.74 estoy redondeando y
lo que hicimos para calcular ese valor
fue tomar esta distancia vertical del
punto con respecto a la recta la
elevamos al cuadrado más el cuadrado de
esta distancia vertical más el cuadrado
de esta distancia vertical más el
cuadrado de esta distancia vertical
esa fue la suma que calculamos en excel
para obtener que el total del cuadro de
la variación con respecto a la recta es
igual a 2.74 o el total del cuadro el
error con respecto a la recta y el otro
número que calculamos fue el total del
cuadro de la distancia con respecto a la
media nuestra media tierra ya es igual a
un cuarto y aquí tenemos un cuarto más o
menos por aquí y aquí tenemos un medio
aquí sería un cuarto
aquí estaría aquí es donde estaría el
valor de la media de jeff déjame
dibujarlo un poco mejor ok
aquí la tenemos esta es la media de y la
medida de tendencia central para los
valores de iu y así lo que calculamos
después fue el total del cuadrado de los
errores con respecto a la media esto fue
lo que calculamos aquí en nuestro hoja
de cálculo aquí lo vemos en la fórmula
es este número 2 - punto 25 que es la
media de la 10 y luego le vamos al
cuadrado eso fue lo que hicimos para
cada uno de los valores de y lo sumamos
y obtuvimos el valor de 22.75 entonces
esto es igual a 22.75 así que si tú
quisieras este es el error que la recta
no explica
este es el error total la variación
total de estos números así que si
quisiera saber cuál es el porcentaje de
la variación total que no está explicada
por la recta dividiría es este número
entre este otro número que tenemos
entonces 2.74 entre 22.75 esto va a ser
el total
mejor él
porcentaje esto hace el porcentaje de la
variación total el porcentaje la
variación total no explicada no
explicada
x
variación
en x y esto cuánto va a ser igual voy a
usar excel para hacer el cálculo tenemos
que va a ser igual a este número de aquí
dos puntos 73 dividido entre este número
acá 22.75 y es igual a cero punto 12 que
tenemos por acá entonces tenemos que
esto es igual a punto 12 esto es igual a
cero punto 12 otra manera de ver esto es
que el 12% del total de la variación no
está explicada por la variación en x el
total del cuadro de la distancia entre
estos puntos o la manera que se
dispersan su variación que no está
explicada por la variación en x así que
si queremos la cantidad de variación que
está explicada por la variación en x
simplemente la restamos de 1 tengan
escribirlo por acá tenemos entonces que
nuestra erre cuadrada que es el
porcentaje de la variación total que
está explicada por la variación en x va
a ser igual a 1 - punto 12 que acabamos
de calcular
1 - punto 12 lo cual es igual a 1 -
punto 2 es igual a punto 88
entonces nuestro es re cuadrado aquí es
0 88 bastante bien está bastante cercano
a 11 es el mayor valor posible lo que
nos dice esto o una manera interpretar
esto es que el 88% de la variación total
de estos valores de i está explicada por
la variación en la recta o la variación
en x
variación en x y puedes ver que hay muy
buen ajuste cada uno de estos no está
tan alejado definitivamente cada uno de
estos está más cercano a la recta de lo
que lo está a la media está más cercano
a la recta que a la media más cercana a
la recta que la media está más cercano a
la recta que a la media todos estos
puntos están más cercanos a la recta que
a la media